a horrible scam using your identity in
the 21st century we use nicknames to
disguise ourselves on the internet still
scammers have no problem finding out who
we truly are by digging through social
media and other personal data for
instance they can use this oh synthbot
so if scammers find out your name they
can do all sorts of horrible things they
can hack your social media and make a
copy of your profile then they make a
scam post asking for donations to
support say a sick relative to make this
look real they can even use a fake proof
of identity so if you suddenly come
across a desperate call for the Nations
from a friend online don't rush to your
wallet call this person first to see if
the post is even true don't forget to
practice good cyber hygiene and don't
use the same login and password
everywhere share this video with your
friends and subscribe we've got more
interesting content in store for you